does this look like a conflict in which
calmer heads are prevailing or does this
look like preparation for war while more
US troops deploy to the region
their commander in chief appeared to
ignore the public briefings of his staff
about de-escalating the crisis 24 hours
after he stuck largely to scripted
remarks justifying the missile strike
which killed Qasem Soleimani Donald
Trump issued a series of threatening
tweets let this serve as a warning that
if Iran strikes any Americans or
American assets we have targeted 52
Iranian sites representing the 52
American hostages taken by Iran many
years ago some at a very high level and
important to Iran and Iranian culture
and those targets and Iran itself will
be hit very fast and very hard the USA
wants no more threats the 52 hostages
harks back to the beginning of the u.s.
Iranian schism 41 years ago the American
Embassy in Tehran was overrun by
revolutionary students and diplomatic
staff were held prisoner for 444 days
that standoff ultimately caused
President Jimmy Carter a second term in
the White House Donald Trump is evoke in
that memory to justify his
uncompromising approach to this 2020
crisis but threatening cultural as well
as military targets will enrage Iranians
further and carrying out such attacks
could constitute an international war
crime the official mourning for Iran's
top military commander still has three
days to go before his burial in his
hometown the likely retaliation for his
death is forcing the UK to increase
security defense secretary ben wallace
announced that the royal navy would
resume protection of british vessels
through the strait of hormuz HMS
Montrose and HMS defender will be
deployed as they were last year after an
oil tanker was seized and others
attacked
the aftermath of the killing of Qasem
Soleimani has already seen rockets fired
close to the US Embassy in Baghdad
there's also been an apparent cyber
attack on an American government website
this should be the home page of the
federal depository library program much
worse is expected in woods Sky News
Washington